welcome to the church of what's
happening now it's brought to you by
nature box
what do you want what do you do when you
want a snack but all you can find is
junk food you rely on your self-control
to resist the temptation come on give me
a breather you eat the junk food start
snacking healthy with naturebox and
right now you'll save even more nature
boxes offering our fans our family fifty
percent off your first order when you go
to naturebox.com
joey again naturebox.com joey
50 off your first order start eating
healthy and i like to also he likes
sleep you're unique you don't walk like
everyone you don't talk like everyone
you don't sleep like everyone so why is
your mattress one size fits all answer
yourself that listen
i got a mattress plate that's going to
change your life
if you have couples
one side can have it with the other or
the other one can have it the other one
and everybody's happy you understand me
you got 100 nights to try it out go to
helixsleep.com joey and get 50 off your
order again that's helixsleep.com
this is the best mattress money can buy
oh [ __ ]
watch that monkey
it's coming at you direct tonight
[ __ ] what
hit it
[Music]
you want it you got it [ __ ] the
church what's happened now
big brown
lisa
[Music]
[Music]
you got that old school wallet son
[Music]
let's do this [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you thought the week was over it's just
starting [ __ ] thursday baby hit
it
here we go
brendan schaab in the house what up
brother thank you for stopping by yeah
man all right so here's my thing on it
you ready talking about jonbenet yeah
first of all
when that happened i've been through
that system in boulder
and when the germany case happened that
community wasn't ready for something
like that i mean and both
boulders had some wild
when i got sentenced when i got arrested
in boulder
there was a skinny wiry guy
michael something
he hung out with some other nerdy dude
not bad guys but the one guy talked
about the piece that has he had
you gotta see my girlfriend she's the
hottest man she was 12.
then we got transferred after three or
four days in boulder county we got
transferred to summit county jail
okay summit county jail
it's like a paradise yeah handball your
own clothes at 10 o'clock the guard goes
to safeway
and brings you chips and selling this
and [ __ ] to watch tv
no no no this is a complete different
cigarettes
reefer the whole [ __ ] thing
they said i was gonna stamp there for
two months but they shot me to
uh canyon city and you get processed and
then they sent me to goldman
i did my time i got out of jail i never
thought of anything or anything i'm
selling cars that boulder toyota
and one day i hear these sirens go on
and i get home and i watch tv and
they're boulder's unlocked now
boulder's on lockdown
not allowed to leave your house white
people scared of [ __ ] white people
scared to death lock that [ __ ] down
what a rich one was this guy with a hot
piece of ass
broke out of jail from canyon city
hitchhiked to boulder
went to by uh lee hill
which was one of those mountain you know
we're talking about the bus stop yeah a
little northern moore i guess
anybody can tweet me and correct me on
this
and he saw four kids target practicing
he went up to the four kids he goes
forest range you put your guns down the
four kids put their guns down he took
the guns turned them around and shot all
four god damn this is boulder 1990 bro
jesus christ shot all four kids took
their guns i heard this there was a
manhunt in boulder seven o'clock
boulder lockdown he went into kmart and
bought ammunition
so that centralized the
the third to search in north boulder so
they made it they came to the toyota
dealership
did the whole thing now if you're headed
on to longmont from boulder yeah on that
street uh
isis i don't know what it's called
whatever iris iris iris if you go on
that street
in the old days after about uh maybe
three quarters of a mile there was there
was an old blues club
right off that street that was very
popular in boulder people had i had
never been in i'm not gonna lie the
entire
i never went in there but i heard that
through people that that's where like
[ __ ] famous blues people wanted there
to play i don't know the name of it or
whatever
so that night i went to bed and the next
day what happened was this
she wrote him a letter
and told him she was leaving for another
guy he went bananas and broke out of
jail that's the power of [ __ ]
he broke out of jail he tried to get up
to her house she had moved
he got the four kids he shot him and
then he kept calling her
and i guess the cops traced the call
and she told her that she would meet him
by that bar right off iris
in boulder that nice neighborhood she
would meet him right there cops the cops
were waiting and when he showed up
they shot him they had that thing and
they shot him and they shot him in the
neck doesn't end here oh no he goes to
the hospital critical condition really
die
there's only two surgeons who could do
that surgery in boulder or in denver one
of them was one of the kids father one
of the kids he shot oh his father [ __ ]
his father's like [ __ ] you and die they
saved his life and that dude went back
to jail damn that happened you know is
he still in jail
he's probably he's killed yeah he's
under the [ __ ] jail he's
never seen the light of day i don't you
know like they had [ __ ] like that in
boulder in 87.
they had
this kid that owned the pizza he
there was a bows above
it was pizza
competitor
in the old days and he was on south
boulder and [ __ ] the kid quit the pizza
business his father's business
and got a job with me selling cars i was
going to use a ceo at the time great kid
kid never drank never smoked up one
night he's walking his dog by
30th and iris
there was an albertsons there
and he was walking his dog in that empty
lot
and his dog was sniffing something and
he went over to see what it was and he
picked up a bag he took 10 steps
and [ __ ] swat came out fbi right
there they threw him down the floor they
beat him up
they pitched the tent
[ __ ] they they opened up the bag
there was 80 grand cash and 2 kilos of
coke they opened up the coat they tested
it they went to his house raided his
house raided his father's house
you know they just wanted to make sure
that this kid wasn't a courier i guess
they were chasing somebody in boulder
people threw the suitcase out the
[ __ ] window jesus and they sat there
inside of the suitcase they thought he
came to pick it up with his dog
yeah boulder boulder doesn't have a lot
of uh
you know a lot of crime or anything like
that so that jonbenet case shook that
whole [ __ ] shook that whole case and
dot crease you know so after that all
went down and they couldn't solve the
murder doc crease who was the strength
coach at cu moved into that house
he he bought that house and was like and
everyone's like you know what's john
benedict he's like i don't give a [ __ ] i
thought they tore it down enough well
they did now but right after they didn't
he moved there
okay so this is my thing i i worked at
puddle car wash
and he's one of the biggest benefactors
to the cu
organization harold arnold whatever the
guys own his name is i worked there for
years and they do all the city cops cars
and i became friends with all those cops
all the undercover cops
they would come in uh you know whatever
boulder county sheriffs in a [ __ ]
plain cadillac yeah they're on the cup
of cops
but there was this one lady used to come
in who uh was a lesbian very nice i
became friends i didn't know what
happened
do you know what happened when they went
to that house it was a crime scene crime
scene yeah they didn't treat it like it
though they didn't treat it like it they
had a circle breath yeah and they
contaminated the crime scene so even if
they would
at that time i think if they would
arrested the mother of the father and
took them down
that jew was living in new york the same
guy that got oj off barry scheck that
guy was in savage
super savage yeah super savage so they
would have won on the appeal
because the dna was contaminated they
put a blanket on her
bunch of [ __ ] they did a bunch of [ __ ]
they had a prayer group they had a
meeting so that was always people going
in and out they had people going in so
that was my one thing that i thought why
they never made an arrest and number two
when i never made arrests i think that
between you and me i think that alex
hunter
or whatever the da's name at the time or
the mayor yeah
it was such an ugly thing to happen in
boulder
it happens in their lane in the valley
every [ __ ] day it happens in new york
every day yeah
but i don't think they wanted to drag
boulder through it
and at the end what happened the mother
died of cancer mother died of cancer
yeah the father lives i think in arizona
yeah the brother is weird as [ __ ] do you
see him on like dr phil right
not so they're trying to
put it on the brother that he choked her
that he trumps what they think that's
what they're thinking
i think it was one of those things that
boulder couldn't handle bro they weren't
prepared for it i think boulder was
going to [ __ ] their parents
they thought about it and they said
first off every [ __ ]
entertainment
angle is going to be in this city living
here for the next year and a half
disrupting our traffic disrupting our
lives
and in many ways i don't know did they
get away with murder
who the [ __ ] really knows
who the [ __ ] would kill their child you
have a child who the [ __ ] would do that
to their child a lot of it goes back to
the to the brother there's if you look
at certain angles and there's there's a
there's a case for the mom there's a
case for the brother the dad's you know
the dad knows but he's not in on it the
dad knows but there's a big case for the
brother he he was known to do some weird
[ __ ] he'd hit the daughter all the time
he'd do some really weird [ __ ] he was
jealous of where he should get all the
attention then i get this what's
interesting is
i guess jonbenet was sleeping
and the
the snack that used to have and some
weird white people [ __ ] they'd drink
they'd eat pineapple and milk
pineapple and milk was the snack so i
guess the brother got hungry went
downstairs get a snack
jonbenet heard him getting some woke up
went down there she went to reach for
his snack this is the theory that i
heard
and the brothers used to hitting her
grabbed uh like one of those maglite or
something hit her over the head not mean
to kill her he's young seven at the time
hits her over the head and that's where
the problem is the mom and dad didn't
want to lose the the son too once they
realized she's dead so they made it look
like it was that's what they think and
then you look at the ransom note yeah i
mean it's a [ __ ]
goddamn miniature novel like no one's
gonna
go through all that time and they had to
recreate that note it takes [ __ ] like
three it took forever no one's gonna do
that
and then the the ransom they asked for
is the exact bonus christmas bonus the
husband got that year who would have the
information
some weird [ __ ]
either way
when i went to boulder right before i
got arrested but what killed me
what really made me them give me a high
bail was two things
number one there was some dude partying
in [ __ ] boulder who ended up meeting
when i went to jail he was in county he
was getting high
and somebody tried to break in his house
and he jumped off his balcony three
floors and he broke both his legs
goddamn when the cops came they found
the quarter pound the cochlear's house
so they [ __ ] arrested i was gonna say
why did he go to jail then and then
there was another guy right before i got
in trouble 10 days
cuban kid from miami was c.u.o.p student
that means the ceo was giving him a
small fortune to go to school there yeah
to up their latino numbers
he had
a brand new 1987 nissan 300 zx no not
mad at those not mad at those times he's
a probably cuban kid yeah
that's going to see you and
every weekend he would fly back and
forth to miami
and like he went missing for a week
and they found this 300 zx splattered
with blood
and they never found the body damn
which in boulder you'll never find the
body yeah they never find the [ __ ]
yeah
going back and forth to miami every week
wasn't a tip-off that something bad was
happening maybe not you know what he
picked up he's a regular college student
you know you're not looking for a
[ __ ] 20 year old kid with skis
smuggling a [ __ ] half a kia blow
every [ __ ] week you know
it's how you go dressed they're looking
for the guy with the [ __ ] nose rings
you watch that stupid show at night
drugs inc
yeah that's the airport and [ __ ] and
they get the dogs that come to the
airport
they showed a guy last week man with a
[ __ ] baby
he brought his daughter with him god
damn scumbag and they got the suitcase
and he was halfway there and they just
put a hole in it and sugar started to
pour around the suitcase like [ __ ]
they took the kid from him god damn dude
i saw i saw someone got in trouble got
caught they were illegally
smuggling turtles a million dollars
worth of turtles like some special kind
of turtle have you seen that [ __ ]
i was in like the overhead compartment
i've seen a bunch of animals and i don't
know some weird [ __ ] they're trying to
get it was a million dollars worth of
turtles who was like ah [ __ ] coke man
let's get these turtles think how hard i
feel like that's so much more of a
hassle than coke granted if you get
caught i don't think you're doing that
much time right nah they hit you with
the endangered species
of 1842
yeah like what the [ __ ] you doing there
was a lot of turtles when miami that's
why they have all those [ __ ] animals
from time to time
that's why in the news you're going to
look uh come back after the commercial
we'll show you what they found in miami
yeah kid's got a half alligator have bat
living in his [ __ ] house
and the alligator isn't even allowed in
the states because they smuggle every
[ __ ] type of animal into miami
spiders yeah what do you think comes on
those ships with the coffee beans on
them they think comes [ __ ] flowers
[ __ ] spiders and venomous by this
from africa
i'm head to australian someone tagged me
in the thing this dude got bit by he was
a tourist from the us he got bit by an
australian spider and he's he's he's
losing his legs and his arms because of
it yeah
all right i'll stay here all right this
is a dumb [ __ ] question did he get
bit down in australia by this spike yeah
the plane
in australia got bit because you know i
always joke around i really don't like
to travel but i'm going australia for a
live tour and i i was like i keep your
[ __ ] koalas chlamydia off of me
because that koalas have chlamydia what
they yeah they have koalas damn it you
have a chlamydia all all of them do
they're just born with it so and the
humans can get the you know the virus
from them if
whatever you kiss them on the nose or
some [ __ ] i don't know how you get it
and then uh a bunch of australian fans
right be careful sean send me pictures
of guys getting attacked by great whites
then like check this tourist out and
homeboy got bit by some spider and
losing his arms and legs now what is
going on with great whites
same [ __ ] that's been going on
great whites doing great white [ __ ]
they're fine they found 21 there's a kid
in my jiu jitsu class was hawaii
and he's always he serves every day well
yeah did he see that video he started it
talking about the 15 the 15 they found
in long beach and they were just like
people in the water calmly get out of
the water there's 15. why would they do
that because you have to know but you
don't need to hey everybody let you know
you're surrounded by 15 great whites
wouldn't be better hey everyone get out
of the water don't be alarmed get out of
the water then we got water yo there was
15 great whites because because people
are idiots if they just said people
please get out of the water there'd be
someone i don't want to get out of the
water it's my vacation i'm gonna stay in
the water they have to tell like you're
gonna you're about to get eaten
and but i they were like it's swimming
against the shoreline i don't know how
there's like can you imagine 15 great
whites together
they could eat everyone in like two
seconds they didn't do [ __ ] i think
global warming
something is affecting because the last
couple of years
you keep hearing about it
like shark attacks you keep [ __ ]
hearing about it and this kid was
telling me the other day he goes you
know you know you could smell when
there's a shark what the hawaiian said
this yeah they [ __ ] through their skin
put some hawaiian [ __ ] he goes so they
smell like [ __ ] soon as you're swimming
and you smell [ __ ]
there's a shark close by
he goes whenever i'm surfing out in
pacifica without that and i smell [ __ ] i
climb on a rock and within minutes i'll
see the [ __ ] fin go back that
[ __ ] you would you ever do one of those
shark uh cages well that's what i want
to do no you can't do it yeah that's
what i wanna do in australia this is
really the only reason why i wanna go to
australia do that i don't have time to
do it they booked i'm at so many shows i
have no time to jump in the goddamn
cages thank god do you and i i saw a
video some girls in the cage i don't
know who the [ __ ] makes those it's the
same like when you go bungee jumping in
mexico you think that mexican really
[ __ ] made sure the safety of the cord
and the harness and all that they don't
give a [ __ ] what what
so
homegirls in this cage this great what
it's a [ __ ] great white and they're
chumming it you know obeying it it's
coming full speed it goes through this
[ __ ] cage like it's [ __ ] i think i
saw paper mache just
goose
right through i think that one was
absolutely no she got down but it was
[ __ ] thrashing around i think i heard
that was fake like it was a porn star
but i saw one where they got in like
they get into them sometimes they don't
they typically do oh my god [ __ ] that no
cage
listen mind your business you got kids
now when you had no kids that's when you
have a motorcycle and you eat [ __ ] at a
strip club
because it don't matter if the kid wants
to lick your [ __ ] fingers
but once you've got kids you can't do
this you can't do that [ __ ] next thing
you know the kid's got a rash he's
scratching
he does positive for chlamydia how do
you explain that [ __ ] i play around with
the quality [ __ ] that noise
that's the [ __ ] you do in your 20s and
with that i've always wanted to do it
man i gotta you know what i always
wanted to jump off a building too and
see if i can live but i'm not doing it
where did i go last week milwaukee i
went outside
early and i went for a walk i went to
cvs i had to buy [ __ ] toupee a bunch
of [ __ ] and i went back
and i said let me get some coffee it was
like 10 o'clock i haven't really had
breakfast maybe at seven
dog i went downstairs and smoked a
tremendous joy tremendous tremendous one
not a regular one of those joints where
you get really baked outside yeah the
sun's on your face you know milwaukee
and i hear this commotion on top of me
and i look up and i counted 12 stories
up to the window cleaners
those dudes that get on the [ __ ]
heart
[ __ ] that and i sat there for a while
one of my best friends that should make
it eight dollars an hour no
no
my buddy left the [ __ ] great
lucrative drought to go back to new york
to do that he was union
he worked for the company the
the the [ __ ] tower they blew up oh
tower uh the world trade center yeah him
and his brother worked at the world and
he got promoted washing those windows
washing those windows they had contracts
all around the city you're steady
yeah you're making bank you're making
union wages doing work but have you seen
in the wind that sometimes they can like
crash against the thing no thank you
listen uncle joey don't do those type of
jokes well you've been to the comedy uh
comedy works in denver downtown yeah
right next there off lemur square
someone sent me this [ __ ] video some
dude climbs up to the the top there no
it's not that tall it's you know you
know comics are like basting top of the
comedy store downtown somebody climbs up
the top there at flemish square and it's
it's [ __ ] it's lunch hour on a
tuesday
and somebody's just sitting up there
saying he's gonna commit suicide so of
course everyone in their suit and dress
from their nine to five gets their phone
out filmmakers they think he's gonna do
it homeboy does it
hey
face first
how bad stuck
game over head blunt blows up he came
over you died before you hit the
everyone goes ah
it's just i mean i can't watch those
videos me neither i was like oh what's
wrong with you he's gonna he has a
squirrel suit on he's gonna bungee jump
lumber square this is dope some college
kid no some dude just didn't want to be
there anymore when i first moved to
boulder fresh eyed bushy tail
22 years old pocket full of cash
scams out the s i moved to 10 12 14
street
all right
i had a four bedroom apartment with
three other students one japanese kid
didn't [ __ ] speak english
and they cut him off because he had a
white girlfriend
so i paid him 20 a day to cook japanese
food for me every night he'd go to
alfalfa's and buy me the nice meat we'd
make szechuan beef and [ __ ]
then there was a mexican kid who got
smith smitty with me one night and i
robbed him
and he kept begging me for the money
back i knew it was you
he kept saying i knew it was you i
worked hard under the sun for that money
the cops came when i blamed it on me
because they smelled marijuana yeah you
ratting me out
so i gave him like two weeks and i saw
where he hit his money like
like 300
[Laughter]
[ __ ] came and there was a white dude
that played the guitar what happened you
have one of the best memories of anyone
i know oh my god
you have no brain trauma no you have the
cereal all the drugs everything you have
zero brain trauma 19 i had a [ __ ] one
of the best memories i know i had an
email from a friend of mine that beat me
up oh my god saying i don't remember
this whole story why are people asking
me about i told the stronger podcast and
i got back to him
i'm like how don't you remember this
[ __ ] have you always had a good memory
yeah because it's
a lot of like i can remember
big moments and like traumatic moments
or
negative things but i don't like to some
again like your boy who's like dude i
don't remember that [ __ ] people tell me
like you remember this and this i'm like
not really man
a lot of it i don't when i go home i
hear stories and sometimes like oh man i
kind of remember it
but i don't remember but this [ __ ] i
remember like it was yesterday
the conversation how it went down you've
always had a good memory
since i was a little kid i could go away
go back to the same place the next year
and ask for people
my mom would look at me how the [ __ ] do
you remember this [ __ ] you can't see
using your brain though doing stand-up
like most comics i know are super sharp
too i was good with numbers when i was a
child i was you know we had a numbers
bank
okay so
there was a rule at the house
renee would call every day at three
o'clock if my mom was busy throughout
the day
renee would call at three o'clock and
whoever answered the phone had to give
him my mother's numbers for the day
so it was like three combination numbers
like 325 218. running numbers 219. it
was just like five or six numbers
but my mom could ask me a week later
what did i play two two tuesdays ago i
could tell damn you're like rain man
that's [ __ ] crazy this is crazy the
weed didn't do anything because i i
don't think i was that good but i had a
pretty decent memory and now i feel like
most of it's not gone but it's not to
where it was you think the weed made you
look cloudy uh yeah well maybe a little
bit but then i also like i was trying to
think of my fourth grade teacher's name
the other day and it took me like 10
minutes to think of it just like weird
stuff like that
mr bell i figured i figured it out but
it's a formula
see yeah
but i don't know it doesn't make you
cloudy at all sometimes it does with me
yeah it probably took some of the years
away
or certain cloudy thing like like
there's certain things where my memory
is really good because i collect like
football cards when i was a kid and for
the most part even today even the pros
in the nfl i still fall as closely i can
tell you what college they went to
position certain like stats like even
old school things just what college
where they're from very strange man
we have i also have
what do people say when they try to be
cute they go
you have uh photogenic yeah photographic
memory i thought no
photogenic isn't it it's a photographer
photogenic is like your face
will you have a weird way of retaining
worthless information
like somebody told me that one might be
worthless
yeah but the people next daughter them
on the hill in 1985 this is the hill
1985. he'll still
sold weed
and i became friends with him he was
like 22. he looked like cousin it and
she was like 48 just [ __ ] to death
an old hippie chick that smelled
it was a nightmare but they were the
sweetest people in the world and i met
this vietnam vet over there i didn't
know he was a vietnam vet
we started hooking up in the afternoons
he was a little older than i was 10
years older than me
i never knew he was a vietnam bat
president shot
and we would hang out and smoke he would
make me laugh my ass off one day
we're across the fox theater and there's
a bodega there
roses
is that it roses i think man and they
make chicken
in those days
they used to make rotisserie chicken
this is way before boston mark and
everybody else
they were known for a rotisserie chicken
so i go fred hey you want to go up and
get a chicken he goes yeah come on let's
go we split the chicken we're sitting
right in front of rose summer of 85
and there's a kid
on top of the fox theater
we're both stalling to the gills
and he's up there going [ __ ] use all you
know because
a lot of anti uh
anti-society kids go to bold for sure
they get rich parents yeah they send
them there then they go there and they
start talking those big words about
humanitarian totalitarian government
speech all that all that [ __ ] they go
crazy
they go crazy and both sandals this it's
august of 85. this kid's up there
yelling and screaming over the top of
his lungs and again
it's bolder so people are surrounded him
and they're going please don't jump oh
really please don't the cops get there
and the kids and the cops are yelling at
him
and me and ed are sitting there eating
that chicken
like nothing happened
like nothing happened after about
because the kid was yelling we walked in
when we walked into the chicken place
that kid was already yelling
so by the time we walked out there was a
circle and people were colored yeah
coming out going we just call the police
please let them talk to you and right
there i kept eating fred
pepe and once the cops got there it was
like 12 minutes in and we're eating the
salad we got a dr brown's original soda
i'm from new york city doug so when i
saw dr brown's my
black cherry soda are you [ __ ] crazy
i couldn't wait to get back to colorado
and get my ham on dr brown's black
cherry and then there was no diet then
there was nothing you got sugar in that
[ __ ] chance so delicious oh my god
they didn't have doc browns in new york
they had soda coca-cola yeah so i
couldn't wait to get back to colorado
and i [ __ ] grabbed uh
well i'm out there drinking my doc
browns with ed
and i can see others getting madder by
the minute
like that [ __ ] up his whole train of
thought he's trying to tell me stories
about weightlifting and [ __ ]
and finally goes hey you [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you're gonna [ __ ] jump jump you
[ __ ]
and yeah damn man and a hundred people i
didn't say nothing
that was my dog you know what i'm saying
i gotta get your back i was howling
well i was out yes
i knew ed bro for maybe
five or six years before i knew there's
a vietnam vet no
that he was a trained
assassin goddamn
like that's what half a bold is filled
with and people don't know it hippies
and assassins huh it's either hippies or
assassins he would be a video game no
that's what he did in assassins there
was two of them there was one guy that
used to play the bongos on pearl that
was his buddy had asian orange on his
face
he had like a blue medal on he was
telling me it was this guy's guy
like [ __ ] he went to lunch with nixon
like nixon with his cigarettes yeah [ __ ]
this is ptsd now this get all weird
this is 85.
they would go to the vet center like my
friend ed would go to the vet place
and they would give him medication they
would give him money and had a nice
little apartment but i knew that ed was
a vietnam vet for some reason i thought
he was a medic
and one day i went to his house oh my
god
he had everything dog
this guy had everything
like purple heart we never talked about
it no yeah no you know you know there
was a picture of him with a bayonet like
three vietnamese guys
like this guy did not [ __ ] around like
oh
ed what did you do
and bro we got an eight ball one night
he just started breaking it down like by
three he was crying damn he was like i
was 19. i didn't know what i was doing
serious [ __ ] yeah they dropped us off
and they said kill they took us
and he was telling me how they would
pick him back up for three months and
then retrain them and he'd go back out
there that's how it goes and he goes
with 12 of us would go out and six of us
will come back twelve of us would go out
and four of us would come back and he
just started laying stories on me so i
had beeps and both i started having
beefs
and i would go ahead what do i do and he
would go
let me think ed had
a solution to everything
he's been through something he wasn't
going to shoot you yeah he didn't
believe in shooting people
he wanted to blow you up
or light john fire or [ __ ] take it to
chautauqua goddamn tie you to a tree and
put maple syrup on you
and let the bears get you
brother have the gun how could you ever
get elected that would be because i did
it about four times it takes about a day
and a half for a better eat god damn the
only thing they don't need is through
your elbow
and through something i'm like oh my god
savage you know they because that's why
boulder always had a very weird now i
don't know what boulder is
i'm talking about from
when i was there from 80 and i told
spoken to joe about this that when i
lived in aspen
i knew three people up there i knew one
guy doug
he was so high up in the government they
were picking up a helicopter
they didn't even have time for him to go
to aspen airport yeah damn they would
pick him up in the house last time we
went back to boulder denver
denver last august
doing
i have not stepped foot in boulder since
there's no comedy club up there right
since july
since
june 25th of
when you were in milwaukee you go by
yourself
yes i took matt fultron this time
you know there's a lot of comments that
are working they're open up you want to
take him out get him exposure yeah he's
a good kid we get along do you usually
go by yourself you usually bring
something
it depends what comedy club i'm going to
because
yeah because sometimes i'm taking food
out of somebody else's mouth and i've
been there
for the local community so yeah like
they already got the week yeah and i'm
gonna bring a guy with me so i know what
clubs have local guys that are dying to
mike yeah you've been doing it so long
yes i'm sure you go to new york or
something like that you know there's
gonna be some killers yeah there's
killers i gotta i got a gay kid that
opens me in new york that's a bad
[ __ ] with all my heart
funny dude and last year was the big
time first time he went in front of a
big crowd like that
and he did okay the first show but the
second show he got lost
where were you at in new york gotham
gotham is my spot here
i'm back there in november the week
after rogan goes back there i'm there in
uh june yeah it's a great little place
it's time you're really liking this
wide performance love it man love it how
does the adrenaline compare to fighting
uh
adrenaline i watch you before you go up
you're very calm yeah don't drink you're
so sure no yeah
you're not pacing you're not you're very
confident which is good yeah
uh
i want i wouldn't say the adrenaline's
the same because i don't get the
adrenaline i think it's more of i enjoy
it a lot like i never i didn't enjoy
fighting
as weird as that sounds i didn't enjoy
that i enjoyed winning and going to the
back just being relieved and getting
accolades and celebrating that i won the
fight but when i'm in the fight i didn't
i never enjoyed that like i enjoy stand
up i i love i love being up there i just
you know it's just a it's kind of a
different it's a different feeling they
don't really compare they don't
the first two minutes on stage for me i
could stab you in the neck
like that's how much adrenaline and how
much anxiety i have going through my
body
when you're doing i'm assuming when
you're doing like uh because you've been
doing so long doing like a big show like
any show any show like you know the
comedy store yes damn you the comments
[ __ ]
see and obviously i'm news i'm not
trying to compare our experiences at all
in the least bit i've been doing this
for four minutes now but at the comedy
store like i've done finally kids that
sold out vic theater in chicago 1100
people new york you know these big ass
theaters and i'll do a theater in
australia that sold out two shows
nothing makes me more nervous than the
comedy store
why is that you think uh the comedy
store obviously it's not my it's not my
people it's not my favorite people
they're there to see joey diaz and joe
rogan and brian cowan and chris talia
and i'm just you know on this side show
so i to get laughs there's gonna be way
harder for me and i know that that's why
i do it's good it's the best training i
can get but also
you know you go there on a [ __ ]
tuesday night it's
dave chappelle
chris rock joey diaz like you you better
[ __ ] bring something or you know
they're they're not gonna they're not
they're they're just to laugh like it
better be some [ __ ] man like nothing
makes you more nervous than the comedy
store
i used to be nervous about all of them
rather than shout outs you got me beat
no no no no no no no
i'm nervous about all i used to look at
the audience and judge the audience and
get beat up what do you mean so i picked
up a bad habit early on
that is great for any
and it's uh
the guys in the other room kicking the
pads yeah and you're hearing those pads
yeah and you're going oh same thing
happens in comedy
you you go look at the theater it's
beautiful okay and you look through the
curtains
there's a bunch of people with white
hair
and you're opening up with a [ __ ] bit
they're not going to like you and i
don't like you then i don't like it now
you go out there have cocked yeah
so now that that right hand isn't really
releasing you're [ __ ] around you're
hesitant you're hesitant you're not
using your best [ __ ] goes your [ __ ] and
you get back they can smell that they
slowly smell it [ __ ] mile away so
when i first started if i'd see people
with white hair i'd lose it then i got
left and i can lift nine out of ten
times they're left old people like dirty
[ __ ] more than young kids 100 especially
an old couple will lose their [ __ ]
they'll come up to you that's why
they're there
tonight i'm going to take my wife home
and do what you did
you're like they want that uncle joey
but yeah raw [ __ ] no see you lose the
you know you you could lose the war
before you walk in the cage yeah it's
the same thing with stand up yeah in a
new york minute new york minute i mean i
like let me listen as a comic i'm not
cheering for the guy in front of me to
die
as a professional i want the comic in
front of me to do the best he can
so i have to top that lift up your game
that's how you get better as a comment
yeah you know you go [ __ ] it i gotta
follow dave chappelle yeah i don't want
to nobody wants to follow dave ship out
but
you do it yep well to me like only
different like the main difference that
i see is that you like the trash talking
and you're going to fight someone but
then i was like i was thinking like
sometimes isn't the thing like you're
you could be yourself own worse critic
so i know it's scary to go fight
like if you're with your brain all the
time saying i'm scared like that's like
more of a torture sometimes maybe i
could write all day i could write for a
week
and at this level i can still tell you
that it all happens the first 30 seconds
before i go on stage
however i psych myself out
like whenever i used to open for joe in
the old days and red man and were all
friends they used to all have matching
phones
so i would look at that matching phones
and i would get angry
i want to be a bit angered before i go
on stage
but not really angry yeah that'll [ __ ]
up my act yeah but i want to have a
little wing to me like you did something
you spilled the [ __ ] water brendan i
told you not to bring the [ __ ] water
in here brendan you're like joey jesus
right [ __ ] man don't even trip on it
yeah i'm doing that to fire myself up
yeah so if i catch you five minutes
before you bump into me yeah and the set
and you're like i'm going up next
i'll bust your balls for 20 minutes
about that you was like i never did that
jesus christ and then they'll go he's
[ __ ] with your dog that's a
psychological [ __ ] they love it see i
like when like uh last time at the
comedy stores it was you dan cook rogan
i like being the back i'll i'll get all
shut down because i'll get just in my
head i'll go over my set over and over
in my head and i'll get very introverted
which i'm not that way i like to [ __ ]
talk you know i like to talk man but if
i don't have friends back there i really
don't talk to anyone so when i see other
people on that i know i told you [ __ ]
you know yes when i'm back there
and you're like what's up if i like to
get that out that helps me get the
nerves out when i can talk to you and
just tell stories and then i go on stage
and i don't overthink it if that makes
sense same with fighting a lot of times
i'd overthink everything oh he's going
to do this for you dude what he's going
to do this no just go do your thing man
you know it goes he knows this and i
tell people when people drive i go don't
worry about them
do your thing if not you're gonna get
hit by the [ __ ] guy yeah just keep
[ __ ] driving yeah with comedy i like
to warm up with somebody so
it's really weird
they i had a comedy friend once that
told me he used to like to open up with
what happened with his day
so for years just get started i would
reflect on my day and what happened it
was hysterical sometimes because you
have bad days people love when you have
a bed they know about your back they can
relate to it so those first two minutes
were just me
on a rant from the heart
which people know when a rant is fake
100 percent of people know when a rant
is from the heart yeah and it was really
interesting how would it be about what
you're mad about
it could be about missing the bus
whatever missing the train and this
[ __ ] dude got next to me you're not
gonna believe i got arrested this
morning but you're just using that to
get to get going before you [ __ ] it up
you would think in a whole different
that's why i always say so much
comedy is football because you're half
of your life you're living in audibles
yeah half of your life you're living
over more than half i think yeah jesus
christ you don't know how many times
i've gone to the comedy store 15 minutes
set and i'm going to talk about this
this and this and that all and get the
[ __ ] out of that yeah there's something
on the way to the store music
the comic before me
it's something and you have to adjust to
it yeah and it's really interesting the
audible part of it yeah i don't i don't
have a lot of experience like you've
been doing 25 years the only audible
i've had so far is gonna someone asked
me to do a i never turned down a set i
need all the reps i can get right
whatever i do it so i it was at the
improv in hollywood
um they go hey can you come on yeah no
problem man
i go down there yeah you should give me
10 15 minutes you know 10 8 to 15
minutes
i so i just assume i was getting 10 to
15 minutes i get things you have three
minutes
what the [ __ ] you know that's not i've
never done that for you yeah you have
three minutes man you have three minutes
do your thing i was like [ __ ] and
literally when i got there between then
there i had maybe five minutes you know
just kind of figure things out but you
know it didn't go great but you when you
talk about your odds was just [ __ ] like
that but i think that stuff helps i feel
like dealing with that and trying to
adjust whether you hit it out the park
or not helps you down the road i like to
think so the next time you do three
minutes you'll be better at it a set as
a set as a set yeah i always believed in
you know
six minutes
10 minutes 15 minutes i'm really good in
the 10 minute spot like if you go joe
you have a showcase with cbs 10 minutes
you might as well go home
that's my world because i'll talk fast
and i'll do 20 minutes and 10. yeah i
won't let you that's your thing yeah i
just keep punching you in the living
room
i love a short set and it's so weird now
when you have a 45 minute set you have
to adjust your tone
and the speed and let them laugh and let
them sorry
yeah it's so weird and but this is all
the things you learn through experience
it kills me
when like um we talked about this when i
did your podcast yeah when people think
there's a shortcut no shortcuts and
there ain't no [ __ ] shortcuts whether
you want to be a dentist a lawyer
a fighter a plumber a comic an actor
you could take all the [ __ ] shortcuts
you want but i'm telling you the way to
get better than anything is just by
doing it yep just by doing it even if
you think you're getting beat up who
gives a [ __ ]
brought to jiu jitsu today and there's a
kid there that's 265
when he lays on you feels like 9 000
pounds bro
and the last time i went there he got on
top of me i couldn't do anything it's
miserable i couldn't even retain my
[ __ ] guard so i saw him playing
that's the first guy said let's go yeah
let's go which is rare yeah most people
avoid him i'm passing this
motherfucker's guard yeah and i passed
this guard he was so strong
like i'm [ __ ] 297 i'm putting my
shoulder into your chest i'm sure you
got better from doing that though oh
yeah he was so strong bro yeah i tapped
yeah a minute left i had i had one arm
for more i was trying to come warm and
[ __ ]
but it's so weird how even for me with
jiu jitsu i don't go to jiu jitsu to be
a tournament fighter or nothing i gotta
basically breathe to get in shape and to
eliminate the fear of being on the
bottom yeah so for me that's
i put it into perspective the same way i
did with comedy when i first started
doing comedy i said listen there's
nothing i could do there was a
commercial when i was younger and a guy
comes in pennzoil
and the model of penzo on those days are
you either going to pay me now
or you're going to pay me late
which in my mind i always said you're
gonna do the work now
or you're gonna have to go back and do
the work later
you know it's like a lot of the guys
that one last comic standing
they got success from the last comic
standing but they really have 45 minutes
to headline
because you get done with last comic
stand and then you're out headlining all
these clubs
so they would go in 30 minutes 20
minutes and they wouldn't have that time
so their their heyday came and went you
know guys like ralphie may they have now
when they were last kind of standing
alonzo bowden was a well-known comic
yeah why is this he's brilliant she's
brilliant experience is everything yeah
the thing that you have ahead about a
lot of people that you're
you're you're like
in the a-leagues
meaning you're you're doing the comedy
store three nights a week you're on your
left you're at the ice house yeah joe
you know
who else do you go
really uh laugh factory uh comedy store
and ice house those are my three and
i'll do the improv there's young
comedian somewhere right now going man
i can't wait to play the improv one day
i'm gonna kill it and you've got it and
you have it so you have a great
opportunity
it's like those fighters in the ufc
they're like how do you get in there
and try to [ __ ] trust me brother i
realize it too and i run with that [ __ ]
it's super fortunate and that puts a
different feather in your cap
because throughout the years you're
going to go what the [ __ ] am i scared of
i had to follow norman mcdonald are they
oh i guess
i mean [ __ ] the other night comet story
was you that went dane cook and i was
supposed to go rogan but he wasn't there
he was coming from the belly room and uh
sam triple hey shop you gotta go after
uh dane cook and then you introduce
rogan so i was saying between dan cook
and rogan like that my my experience
it's so strange man the way life works
my
my
football career my ufc career has always
been thrown just thrown to the sharks
it's just that for whatever reason
that's
that's how it's been god bless you yeah
a lot of people don't have that
experience you have to have to learn
from being there
yeah you get run over on the end there
you go well i've been fortunate because
the thing that prepared me somewhat of
it and i have a long ways to go but
doing the live find the kid podcast with
brian callan because i'm in i'm at you
know my first shows at irvine sold out
show so i'm used to these crowds i'm
used to that doing that for a year and
then
the comic store goes hey man we'd love
for you to do a set here like you [ __ ]
well what are you like finding the kid
you want me and brian no no
we want you to do can you do 10 minutes
or yeah i mean i could i can figure
something out and that's how it started
so just that that kind of that
experience going through the live frame
the kids traveling around doing these
sold out shows is what
having a good time love it man now is
calvin going to australia with you no no
it's not just you showing how long on
stage are you going to do uh i mean i'm
there for you know i do i do my comedy
so it's half comedy half
you know current events which is improv
on the current events and then i do uh a
breakdown of the big fight and then i do
fan questions so it's usually two hours
to our show for you yeah
just to have those legs yeah like when i
first started doing comedy i had a timer
on
like at six minutes i'm running off that
[ __ ] stage yeah like i wouldn't have
the balls to even say i'm gonna stay up
there for an hour yeah i know my show's
at least 90 minutes yeah 90 minutes and
off the current event i can find some
[ __ ] human or roast in some one of
the
situations you know it's fun man you're
having a good time aren't you time it's
a different type of experience time of
my life man and you you kind of you
control your destiny it's different than
you know that not in fire sports you
don't control your destiny but there's
variables you know you there's there's
certain you might not get this matchup
or this fight or this sponsor you might
not get the main event here that you
know because there's factors you can't
control
this and this journey i'm on now i
control this [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like i had
cyborg in my podcast the other day man
if i was still in the ufc and he heard
that there's gonna be some repercussions
man they might shut me down if i was
working for fox probably wouldn't enter
that podcast
now you can't do [ __ ]
it's just it's just a different lane man
just a different way is there a reason
why you didn't go like the acting route
or or maybe you are i don't know but
it's it like it is a reason why you
chose to stick with comedy i mean i've
had some offers acting i've you know
i've had some
some cool things come up but
you know comedy's hard enough man i'm
behind the eight ball as it is you know
i gotta get going i got a lot of work to
do like i love doing this like this this
is what i want to do you know if it was
some special thing in acting where it
didn't take time away from my family or
comedy i'd be down if it was the right
thing no i i i even meant like just in
the sense when you were finished
fighting or when you stopped fighting in
the ufc and you could you could have
been in like an action movie it seems
like there's a little
less of a barrier to entry like it's a
little easier maybe to act in an action
movie for you or a football team for me
no not for me no because the the the
podcast at the time you know we have a
comic brian i have covered the podcast
so that thing started gaining legs okay
and then you know acton's just you know
i got offered to play oh play the bad
bad guy bodyguard in the movie like i
don't want to [ __ ] do that that
sounds terrible i'm on set just sitting
around you know
uh comedy is something i've always been
fascinated by how long have you been a
fan of comedy oh [ __ ] i mean my this is
what's strange when people hear this you
know my heroes were jim carrey and adam
sandler growing up
how old are you brendan 33
wow
and what was thirty four times when was
the first time you were exposed
to a guy with a microphone how old were
you
think back i mean your dad your mom your
aunt my my mom every saturday night
we're lit religiously we'd watch cyanide
live so you thought you know so you're
seeing i'm seeing all those people on
there those were my heroes that's what i
wanted to do like i [ __ ] anything
saturday live man it's i mean that's
that's my job high school you did not
take a drama class
nothing in denver wasn't there was no
outlet no performing arts in high school
no my my issue was is
in it you know curse and not you i
probably won't be here if i didn't take
the route of sports but you know i was
blessed to some degree with an athletic
body i was good at catching footballs i
was i was the fast kid in class
but you know
so that you usually don't you know do
that in drama and also in denver really
you know my family wasn't no one really
thought about it no nobody ever [ __ ]
thinks about it yeah nobody ever says
you know what i think i'm gonna get into
stand-up comedy because the first narrow
gonna go you're not funny tell me a joke
yeah i know you're not funny that's not
funny my my mom was the first one when
she she saw me do a show at the the
comedy works in um
in denver and she was like uh she's like
when you were eight i was telling people
you'd be getting into some some form of
show business
my mom's really the only one who called
it
brian callum probably like six years ago
i was wrapping my hands in the gym
getting ready to spar some monster i'm
telling everyone story and they're
laughing he goes you know you're gonna
do stand-up event joey you're [ __ ]
crazy i'm literally wrapping my hands
about to spar this [ __ ] behemoth and
he goes you're gonna be doing stand up i
mean you're [ __ ] you're out of your mind
you're [ __ ] crazy you know brian like
you're [ __ ] crazy
so my mom and brian are the ones
you know it's there's a guy still talk
to jim andy in fact i've had i've had
him call into the store onto the podcast
twice the beginning of the year
because he's the guy that turned me on
into he turned me on into goals
when i used to sell cars she's gonna
come in no you gotta write goals down
every day blah blah blah
and i would tell them man i'm going to
start doing comedy and [ __ ] i would do
like little shows in the showroom
and i'd be ripping those people outside
and stuff
and one day i went to the back to have
his son watch one of the cars
and his son comes up to me goes you know
man my mom and dad have been having a
lot of problems lately
he goes to tweet on the drive here he
said he felt like
quitting his job and just getting in the
car even taking you on the road this is
four years before i got into comedy yeah
and people were telling me like listen
bro
give it a shot i mean are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you know the type of person
you have to be yeah they do one
background check
and then like they're like when i
finally don't do background checks
there's no background check i didn't
[ __ ] know i don't know
i thought they were going to give me
background check blood tests or some
[ __ ]
but it's it's uh like i still talk to a
lot of my friends from grammar school
and they won't say we knew it they'll
say you were just funny yeah like you
were funny so we had an idea somewhere
but then you became a criminal so he
became a criminal so kind of took a
[ __ ] weird road but he came back
around you found yourself are you one of
those guys joy where you say we think
it's your calling you think you're put
on this earth to be a comedian
not at all you don't think so you don't
think you have a gift
no no
i laugh at night i got these [ __ ]
idiots
i swear to god you're crazy man
you also have a special skill set
one of the top comedians in the world
joe rogan labels you the funniest man in
the world it's funny because i still
remember being in front of the deli we
were hung on from jersey
you know what i'm saying like i could
still close my eyes and see me and
valeno and ascalis and [ __ ] running a
bunch of us
and you to talk in that circle
you better be you gotta bring your [ __ ]
yeah you could bring your [ __ ]
and i remember that i was always closed
out the circle yeah
like i let them do that [ __ ] and i just
go on a [ __ ] rant
you know i killed my dick and i chased
somebody
and they would go [ __ ] bananas you
know i never ever ever i watched it on
tv
i used to listen to richard pryor albums
and it what blew me away about richard
pryor the first time i heard him was
i come from cuba
i had never heard that type of language
like i heard my mother say [ __ ]
or [ __ ] or something not like
richard pryor but nothing like richard
pryor like i took richard pryor home
more
and it wasn't the stand-up aspect
it was to what the [ __ ] was he doing
and then i took the stand up i watched
some calling specials yeah david brennan
was big i still remember freddie prince
yeah when freddie prince was rocking and
rolling
but prior was the one that really bit
into it for you and i bought
bicentennial [ __ ] is it something i
said i mean i bought all those albums as
a fan game changer for you i watched the
movie i was there when you lit himself
on fire
i lived through all that drama i was a
fan of his
and then uh
i don't know i feel like there's some
comics you can you can look at and like
i can see how he does it i don't know if
i have those skills but i can i can see
what he's doing you know like he wrote a
bit he's doing his thing
and then there's other comics like my
hero is jim carrey
i felt like i looked at him was like out
there i mean that i can't do any of that
there's no [ __ ] if that's stand up and
that's what i thought stand-up was like
i didn't have the george carlin's all
that stuff i thought that was stopping
there was a ventura the first one what
oh my god
sure and part two i'll ask the first one
is my shirt you're the second one i love
too i said the first one i didn't want
to go i took my nephew
i took my nephew and my daughter like
i'm bold
and i was howling
game changer bro
for my my mom allowed me to miss two
weeks of school i saw it goddamn eight
times my mom worked uh crosstalk in
sherry creek mall there's a theater
there i would i would pretend i was sick
my mom knew i was doing she'd bring me
her to her work and then she would give
me four dollars i'd look at it was 11
o'clock movie 11 a.m i'd [ __ ] go over
there i'd go to mrs fields cookies i get
a cookie sandwich with icing double
chocolate chip vanilla ice in the middle
get my ticket and sit there day after
day after day i was [ __ ] obsessed
with it so i used to sell cars at cherry
creek dodge jeep yeah there you go doug
dandy dug
i used to shoplift those malls i used to
go to movies there yeah man
that was for cherry creek
you know now that you said it i gotta be
honest i cannot lie to you the path was
very simple like it was laid out for me
like it was laid out for me very scary i
went to prison
before i got locked up there was a guy
that i did not like too much when i
worked with him
we didn't like each other and one day
this guy came up to me
and he goes you know you don't think i
like you i don't i don't know if he's
like me or whatever
i'm alone on the straight side he goes
do you know what i did
before i retired and took this job as a
sales manager
and i go no this was
two weeks before i got locked up
two weeks before i got locked up he goes
when i got arrested in bold i was
working at bill crowd subaru on 28th
street this one was on 28th street
grant that was the guy's name god bless
his so
i had worked there and he didn't like my
style of selling he didn't like that i
was like a [ __ ] savage
and he came up to me because i don't
like it so i just stayed away from yeah
and about a week late he came up to me
you know what i did before anything
because
i was the booker
for one of the casinos in vegas
and he goes i gotta tell you
you might have a career as a stand-up
comic
and i looked at them like oh are you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] crazy then i got
arrested
thought went right out the window like
it wasn't brendan to my my little girl
at the house wasn't even a thought damn
it's like if i come to you and say you
know what you should play the harmonica
and you're like joey i'll think about
that yeah okay let me go get a fight
that's how quick like by the time i got
in the car and i went and got that right
now you're thinking about it that bag of
coke it was gone like i never thought of
it was that crazy to you like it was
like the harmonica like you you you
wouldn't even consider it's like me
coming to you and going you know what
lee you got a little orange you should
play the [ __ ] boat
like you know at an orchestra the
hollywood bowl i'll hook you up
i got a connection down there that's so
crazy when you think about it like i
just got my car and went home and then i
got arrested went through a process
ended up at camp george west and golden
let me ask you this joy how what how old
were you when you did your first set was
it open mike
yeah it was open mic at the denver
comedy works on tuesday night three
minutes and how old were you
32 so
i got locked up at 25 maybe i'm wrong
maybe it was a little early we'll count
it down i got locked up at 25
when i was in there
[ __ ] would happen and they would always
in the kitchen no in the kitchen
i would i was a stock clerk and i would
[ __ ] around with the black inmates yeah
if the food wasn't good i'd go don't do
it
yeah i'd yell across this the thing the
brothers would go
i go like this to them
don't do and they go god damn it we
gotta eat reserves again because they
all had food in their rooms yeah
so one day the projector broke and i
would go on stage they would go cuba go
and something happened
that they said tell them what happened
today like it was one of those things so
i'll tell you what happened [ __ ] mr
yarbrough by that one cuz you're a good
storyteller something like that and then
like a week later they said the
projector broke and they go cuba go up
there and crack some jokes and this went
on for about four or five weeks so it's
kind of your first open mic
kind of principal from the black guys
they were scary junkies working the no
material working in the crowd material
just working at straight black mexican
white look at this [ __ ] dude
but they're looking for entertainment
and they all dug me and they all got
along with me and never had any beef
and then there was this white dude from
buffalo who killed his wife and her
boyfriend
and he was at the end of a 22-year beat
and then he had to go to buffalo and
serve eight years [ __ ] and he rolled his
own cigarettes and he was very nerdy and
he knew about every book
he would get the deep arguments about
nietzsche with everybody and [ __ ]
and i would go in there every day after
because my job was very limited my job
was like two hours an hour and a half
and then i had the rest of the day off
to about 4 30.
so i go to the library and read the
paper the sports page and i'd return the
book
and one day bro he came up to me they
gave me a notebook
which is big in jail
like to get a notebook you know those
old hardcover ones yeah that looked like
he didn't hit the acid and they're black
on white and then it's his name and
subject
like it was one of those and he goes
take this
and i go why and he goes so you can
write your jokes like he was like like
like this guy killed his wife
and the guy that was cheating on him
with
but comes up to me with a note but he
just take this
because you're going to need this you
should write your jokes on here like he
was happy he gave me something i'll
never forget and i go what's this for
you so you can write your jokes man he
goes you did really good last week
i'm like i'm not a comedian
i just go up to the [ __ ] around
and he looked at me like
you know so wait a second when you go up
there on thursdays you're not prepared
i don't know when the [ __ ] do you see me
writing i don't know where the [ __ ] am i
gonna write yeah and he goes listen man
when you go out of jail you should try
this this is a guy who killed his wife
yeah i'm gonna listen to you
so done
done did i think about it after that
yeah
maybe once or twice maybe they're on to
something
but then i'm like what the [ __ ] the
guy know if he knew anything about
entertainment he'd be leds up in the
manager
and what the [ __ ] does the other hippie
joey you know if he does everything
yeah
and i got a job roofing
i went to work with my in-laws and so
you're in prison for how long
four or five about 14 months oh that's
it i go to boulder i start selling cars
okay and then after i get out of the
boat i take another halfway house i go
to work for my in-laws
and i work on a roof in denver for like
six or seven months
then they make me an estimated they send
me the training school and i go to
different rubber carlisle and goodyear
and they all trained me on how to
measure their rules and [ __ ]
so there's one winter like uh you know
like and and i tell people all the time
especially boulder boulders only then
the bold is only cold the last two weeks
of december the first two weeks of
jackson yeah it's not bad that's it yeah
i think it's all snowing oh my god that
second week of january it was coming
down and we couldn't work
there was a high low dropping off
materials so all we had to do was go to
the roof shovel the roof
and then put the materials on the roof
and we were going to go all to eat lunch
but something happened with all the snow
that they couldn't get the thing
so my brother-in-law goes dog do you
want to go to the diner and get
everybody green chili
boulder make some good green chili now
huh boulder has something this is this
is like south dakota okay this is before
they developed them off to 70 like one
of those warehouses that's real long but
two blocks away the green chile was
money and you could either sit in the
booth to go up to the counter
and i just walked up to the counter
there was a rocky mountain post
and you know like when you open up a
paper just open it rocky mountain news
there's denver post right now i gotta
confuse you know when you open up a
paper like that just to see this yeah
just like that's going on here
right there big bowl lettuce
they said do you want to be a stand-up
comedian what the [ __ ]
and there was a picture andy payton i
still remember the comedian like up
there and said
because roseanne had just hit a deadman
she ought to start there so still but
she had just hit out of denver she took
some of the writers with her you know
some of those writers from denver wrote
her first hour
denver now is [ __ ] hopping people
people don't realize that roseanne you
got her
[Music]
that's
start
denver and then the blue note in boulder
nobody even knows about the blue note
that was a jazz brother they just
thought of coke and they burnt it down
oh yeah the blue note was where
roseanne jeff harms
todd jordan returns those guys
there was a crew of them that had an
improv troop
jeff
the guy who read me the riot act that i
almost killed one night matt
woods matt barry is a gazillionaire now
he writes after shows and something's on
right now that says yeah
he keeps writing so that little crew in
denver
helped roseanne
so
i'm in this diner and i opened this up
brendan and there it is do you want to
be a stand-up comic another sign joey
and it was just like a
comics flock and if you opened it up
it had
like the open mics in town
what night you had a call but in the
bottom it said cu boulder
three-week stand-up comedy course 35
hours
sundays one to four
i signed up
i took the three-week class what was
that class like
you went up there he broke it down for
you he brought a notebook in and you
broke it down he told you what books to
get
and it helped him you'd review the books
and then he made you do three in one
minute
at the end of three weeks
and after class he goes can i talk to
you for a second he goes listen man
i don't know what you're playing with
somebody because you got a future in
this [ __ ] he goes if you like him i'll
help you out that goes a long ways [ __ ]
yeah he goes at least you're on to
something
so he took my number and then
they opened up a comedy club in
westminster
called uh africa with the wits end
and i went up there and i applied and i
used him as a reference and they gave me
the job as a dorm man are you a
religious man joey i am now because i'm
50. are you young
no it was a path you're absolutely right
i was you're absolutely right yeah a
bunch of signs there and then i took the
dj booth and i took the bar back
and then it took me i'm not gonna lie to
you bro it took me six months to get on
the stage the first time maybe eight
months i you know i would cancel the
night yeah i would call they'd give me
the spot
then i call them this time my car blew
up or some [ __ ] like that [ __ ] up no but
this is the beauty of it
i got on stage july 18th no june 18th in
1991.
i got on stage the second time
july something
the meantime i was a doorman
that i was a dj i was the everything i
was a doorman that i became the dj
that i bar back and then
i got on stage twice in august
and in september i got on stage one time
in boulder and one time in new york city
i went to new york city they cleaned my
head their house wasn't doing well
my house at the time me and my wife and
the baby
it wasn't clicking i was i was
roofing from six to six and i basically
come home take a shower and go to the
comedy club took that
it wasn't challenging
i went to new york i made a decision i'm
gonna still do comedy but i'm gonna
work on the relationship
and i really did and one day i come in
in october and she looks me clean
i gotta tell you what really happened
like i really wanted to do stand up
but
nobody was gonna go for it
you understand me there was no way i
could do it
meaning
was it tough to tell people are you
gonna do it financially
the situation i was in
the people i was surrounded with at the
time it just wasn't going to work for me
to do stand up sure there was no way
like i could still keep my day job and
do sets at night that was the plan keep
the roofing job get rid of which ends
tough when you have family and do the
sets at night because you're also not
that young either oh please 21. so no i
got on stage 91 first time i got on
stage i was 28 years old i lied to you
guys i just didn't know it was 20 to 32.
so
it was tough
like brendan it was tough like it was
burning in me yeah like i knew that this
is what i wanted to try at least but you
know going down that road this family
lives right [ __ ] this family like we had
bought a condo already
we had done a lot of things together we
had a baby but the relationship was
slipping
i just thought this was a hump in the
road with the relationship but i kept
thinking about jesus christ
so this is what i'm going to do the rest
of my [ __ ] life i'm going to work on
a roof monday through friday
saturdays i got the baby
and sundays me and her take the baby up
to the inlaw's house we eat dinner
and we listen to the same stories about
[ __ ] germany over and over again
every [ __ ] weekend is this it and
then one day when i'm 65 i get to go
[ __ ] watch this is it
this is what you're [ __ ] telling me
and i mow my lawn and i shovel snow [ __ ]
you that's my activities
i was [ __ ] dying i'm like i can't
believe i can't believe that as an
american
or anything else that they make you go
to college at 18 to pick your [ __ ]
card for the rest of your life when you
have no idea how to wipe your [ __ ]
[ __ ] they want you to pick your
[ __ ] major and label yourself so now
you're 21 you're 60 000 in debt it's
just gonna say any debt and now you have
to pick your choice and you realize you
don't want to say what i [ __ ] want to
do 60 000 is nothing there that's what
that yeah that's the that's and that's
what happened i'm like what the [ __ ] and
i got a kid and i got a [ __ ] wife
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna quit the
comedy job and i'm gonna [ __ ] roof
and i'm gonna maybe mondays tuesdays and
wednesdays after babies and sleep i'll
go out and do jokes i bought judy
carter's comedy workbook yeah i bought
gene parades how to write comedy i mean
i did everything i could i was trying to
write right right right right
i went down to boulder broker you know
what that is yeah the meat market on
wednesdays
they did comedy there on tuesdays wow
and i went and baked my way out there on
tuesday nights baseline there right on
36 and baseball the guy said joey i
don't know i got a magician as the host
come on
let me go up there and do time i got up
there on tuesday and he goes joe you're
not bad
this is good they liked you he goes yeah
the magician's kind of rusty like give
me time
and all of a sudden a month later he
calls me goes hey man
uh beck's beer
is back still oh yeah beck's beer is
doing a national comedy competition and
this the the regionals they're gonna do
them here every tuesday
so he goes i want you to come down and
do the contest
and i was fired up i went down there and
guess what brendan i [ __ ] won damn i
wanted a tuesday maybe my seventh time
on stage i had a stupid joke about
godzilla making a comeback and coming
out of the hudson and [ __ ] and chinese
people dying i mean i didn't even know
what i was saying i was nervous i would
do real fast
and i took a loan out my friend came to
me because i got a car
it's perfect for you
give me four was up to 67
so i didn't know when i get the 4 000.
so i gotta go i'm gonna have to four
that
so i said you know what i went up to
university of colorado and i signed up
for [ __ ] nine classes i just let me
see if i could get away with this
and right there i applied for a 2625
loan
and like two days later they're like
yeah come pick it up friday so yeah i
picked up the 26.25
i took a thousand on my account i bought
this car
and i think i made 2400 or something on
the car i don't [ __ ] remember but i
made a good piece of money and i thought
and i went right back to the school the
next day i said i gotta resign my credit
so i'm just gonna pay you back the loan
and i paid back the loan damn that's a
little hustle and about three weeks
later i walk in my house and my ex-wife
is sitting there with the lead in the
head she goes you never told me about
this
i said you think paid for that [ __ ]
car last month and everything i go i
made 20 i sold the car
and she goes i gotta tell you i'm not
i'm not uh
and brendan i gotta tell you something
at the time my mom died like i didn't
have a good i didn't have a bad
childhood i just didn't have a family
type child and when i was 19 everybody
was talking about [ __ ] yeah i already
knew i wanted to get married yeah like
when i was 19 everybody was talking
about street 54 and getting that dick so
i'm like this [ __ ] ain't for me like the
player left i want a wife i want a kid
i want what i never had yeah so for the
first time i had this but it just didn't
feel right
and this [ __ ] looked me straight in her
face brother and she goes listen
i'm gonna move back
so i'm done and i'm gonna think about it
for divorce i'm gonna take the child
while i'm split custody white girl
white girl let me tell you something
when you know me dog for the first 30
seconds
it's stunning [ __ ] yeah a little bit
but after that a clown was driving over
me no and all i even thought about is
now i can do comedy yes
it was almost a relief oh my god
and i was in love with her the way and i
loved the baby but i couldn't deal with
her anymore we had gone through
everything we could together she did you
a favor she did me a favor he was
[ __ ] crazy
like when she said that to me
i didn't know how to feel yeah like i
the regular guy if a regular guy didn't
have anything to look forward to he
would have collapsed yeah i didn't
because i'm like i mean finally it was
35 seconds later when that dog came in
my mind i go oh my god i can do comedy i
could do [ __ ] comedy though later
[ __ ]
i lost a daughter over it yeah you know
i dedicated myself to this you know
but i always knew even if i stayed in
boulder i wasn't gonna be her father the
way i was supposed to i just saw the car
you talked to her now no we still
haven't talked 10 12 years now really i
hit her up on twitter two weeks ago
and she's still
man we're not gonna talk for a while
yeah
that has to bother you a little bit
it bothers me because
i see
the relationship i have my four-year-old
tonight which by the way almost didn't
let me come here but
my 15 month old almost didn't like me
let me come i was sick at the crib teddy
where you going
she only asked me twice a week now
tonight she goes i gotta go to work she
goes maybe you shouldn't go to work
tonight maybe you should stay home and
watch kyle wally kazam with me
she goes and she started reading off the
episodes earlier it's tough man victor
the villain and [ __ ] the mom whatever
that stuff if i don't have a set i have
people ask me new podcasts all the time
yeah no no i'm home too i'm [ __ ] home
i'm homeless if it's not dire important
i do not [ __ ] around at night it's gonna
have an envelope yeah friday i'm going
to the family dance the school dance oh
nice i'm gonna eat some stars of death
i'm gonna get [ __ ] up put some visine
in my eyes and i'm taking the whole
[ __ ] family to this you know you need
to do that and now you lose your family
you don't have a family and then
whatever
what what
you only say a man without a family is
not a man yeah a man who doesn't spend
time with his friend i didn't know that
when i was 26 yeah i thought your wife
was somebody who stabbed him in the ass
once a week she did your laundry and she
cooked nah man boy was i mistaken at
that age i was a [ __ ] animal you're
young and this is why i got what i got
but it was weird when she told me
she was done it was like i hadn't i went
right for kindly like she was gone maybe
a week and i i already had a little she
did
the biggest favor she could have done
that's how i justify it i mean i'm still
angered that i look at this
four-year-old i see how tired i am with
her
jackie and me were even tighter
so for her to turn on me like this for
her not to talk to me something was said
to her well she's only get one side of
the story something was done the mom's
going this is your dad that's what
[ __ ] happens if she would just sit
down how old is she now 27 come on yeah
something would happen she's old enough
now where she can make a decision where
you at least want to hear your dad out
and because of this there's times i'm
going to contact an attorney i'm like
press charges like i really do i got a
case here
but i go you know what are you gonna win
out of that joey it yeah it has to be up
there i want to hit it like a jew i want
to hit him in the pocket
i want to make him pay i could probably
get some type of settlement i don't need
to do that though
absolutely
it's up to that 27 year old to figure
out that one of my dad's not a bad
[ __ ] guy yeah what am i gonna do so
i'm not i can sit here banging my head i
can take a plane to aspen where she
lives and maybe get charged with
something
she'll come around again
man i'm getting straight that that's
what bothers me besides that no i'm not
bothered at all i got a second chance
and i'm not missing a [ __ ] beat
people look at me what the [ __ ] are you
here listen
all this [ __ ] this is nothing you could
die and this is you can't take nothing
with you i can't take the microphones
this mule
i would take this to the deepest debt
like if there was an earthquake right
now they would find me under here
this is the best bang ever of all time
this is known to [ __ ] put people into
trances and [ __ ]
you know but it's like
uh i don't know i'm not angry at all
yeah i have a second chance and i try to
do the best i can and i'm like you you
don't have a [ __ ] envelope
i love you to death i can't do it though
it ain't happening man and even with the
envelope sometimes
i gotta stay home and pay attention over
there the wife everybody needs to pay
attention i turned on a tv show in uh
new york that's gonna be gone for six
eight eight happening be gone for six
weeks take me away from my kids six
weeks ain't happening
and you know what what i'm gonna do take
a plane here on friday and get back on
the plane sunday [ __ ] you and then
monday you're walking around rolling
wounded and sadly you're walking around
you're like a zombie man your kid
recognizes that
it's the law diminishing returns if i
learned anything out of cu
anything
with intro to mac microeconomics
it's the law of diminishing returns yeah
well the best is saying learn how to say
no to [ __ ] right
well there's a lot of [ __ ] listen when i
moved here i'm not gonna lie to you at
all brendan i did everything
i did everything i did everything except
extra work yeah
if you had five shows in one night and
your show didn't pay i'd still be there
yeah because i knew
the result
the result would be i'm only getting
better yeah you're working on your crap
you would go and tell your friends i got
your days to do 20 minutes mom he's a
[ __ ] sucker you're going to suck a
[ __ ] yeah
because like i got your audience so i
did what the [ __ ] i wanted i tried new
jokes you know you you'd do three four
sets a night i would go to
uh boyle heights i would go to [ __ ]
oh we used to go in the hood jack yeah
that's the training ground i don't even
know who still has rooms but those rooms
are tremendous
those little mexican rooms as i call
them where they sell tacos outside your
bar and [ __ ]
mondays tuesdays some of them give you
35 some of them give you 50. doesn't
matter yeah you're just going out to do
sets and get better in front of
different defenses yeah these people
have a tv in it yeah
these people have a tv huh it's like
when i was the house emceeing the broke
bowl the broken comedy night was 15
bucks plus you got a steak and a baked
potato
and a bowl of shrimp remember they were
known for shrimp whenever you went in
there yeah here's the problem
i got to be funny enough
for you to put that steak down yep
you're competing with the two different
different
animals yeah so when you go to these
bars and then the spanish bars as i call
them
they're people they're human beings half
of them are sitting half of them are
standing
half of them are shooting pool and now
they got to stop shooting pool
and the other half were watching that
[ __ ] lego game yep and we had to shut
it up people know that you better be
funny [ __ ]
there's you know what i'm saying it's a
level of commitment so you get
to face more defenses
you're
and you're like oh [ __ ] i should have
used that joke it don't matter because i
gotta send it dirty and marina del rey
i'll try it there they're not i got 11
15 at the comedy store yeah and in those
days i didn't care what time i got to
the comedy store i'll get there they'll
put me up i'm on the list yeah so i
didn't even look at the clock at the
comedy store it didn't even matter i was
just gonna get there at midnight and go
up in front of eight people anyway maybe
12. you know what i'm saying so
it's a system
the endurance of it like it's just you
know it was great man
it was crazy and i did the same and
believe it or not i had the same system
in colorado yeah
mondays i did the mondays i did the
outback
in boulder
i crossed into the public car washing
like an australian bar
they had a back vault that seated 20.
mondays i do that two to do the comedy
works wednesdays i do club 52
off of commerce
commerce city yeah color city i'm just
sitting here [ __ ] guy was nervous
impersonated
and you got to follow him put that in
your pipe and smoke it's crazy thursdays
i did el torinos and cherry creek down
there
exit you know what you were talking
about yeah they gave you 25 hours coupon
and a free dinner to do stand up so you
always had the free coupon yeah things
got bad let me get four bucks where you
going el torino
so what are you working on now you got a
working special what's the
since our last shot i i shot my special
october
i just started throwing things
yeah and i haven't really
put nothing on paper yet
the last month i've been putting [ __ ] on
you know i could come up with 10 minutes
in your city
i could come up with 10 minutes about
the flight and your city for sure you
know so right there i had 10 minutes
that i knew
i may have 10 15 new but the basic of
the act is the same and i got sick of a
dog so last saturday when i got on stage
in michigan i go that's it i'll never
say this material again feels good i'm
home right now till july 18th i'm
working i have break in the kitchen no i
have bread that's it and what i've been
doing lately is getting up early and
going to mariette
right in front i don't want to
i come home i hang out with the baby i
take him to school
then i do another hour or two of writing
and then i do whatever i have to do like
monday i had a meeting
tuesday just couldn't i had to sleep and
today i went to jiu jitsu you see you
see netflix is they're they're focusing
obviously they still have their hours
but they're they're focused on 30
minutes right they offered me a half
hour so that's that's probably what i'm
gonna feel like you were [ __ ] slow
yeah i would slowly never have the first
[Music]
or i could take those [ __ ] on a
juggernaut of a ride yes
yeah i'll take him to niagara new york
that's a fun [ __ ] yeah take him
to a
there's a couple clubs that you walk in
there
and as you're leaving you're like this
club is perfect to tape yeah uh some
type of spatula i thought of you right
away when i heard that no there's a lot
of opportunities you know i'm just
sitting back
you know man i'm the type of guy take my
set seriously this is the first time my
life this is happening yeah and i
learned a lot of this from joe joe once
told me because you know they
interviewed joe dimaggio and he goes
every night you got to play your heart
out
because somebody might be watching you
might die that night yeah you had a
shitty game you know you know whatever
it really hit me and i was like he's
right and that's why i have a problem
with the comedy store also what do you
mean i have a problem with the comedy
store now not personally or anything i
still love it
it's
lesser bro
i was thief and
i was [ __ ] doing crazy [ __ ]
you know i didn't know where the [ __ ] my
life was going and all of a sudden i
fell into this comedy store
before i got to the comedy store i read
like 10 books on comedy and they all
mentioned the [ __ ] comedy so
come on this most legendary place this
is the place to be yes guess what still
is guess what what's up even though i
got the felonies
even though my kid don't talk to me even
though i never really got the [ __ ]
college degree at the end
even though i had all these shortcomings
guess what bro i was a regular at the
store made by mick smitzy yeah that's
like being a gambino that's a big deal
carlo gambino making a gambino like that
that's
don't matter
maybe again
[ __ ] that [ __ ] okay biggest not you
know with nobody in this town i mean dog
brendan they all hated me that's joe
rogan joe rogan i'll sit here and tell
you people used to tell them comics
comics like managers agents
comedy club owners would tell joey he
you can't bring him here no more and joe
would love it why because i was a you
know loud and dirty
and but then something happened
i booked a movie
and once you book a film people look at
you differently whether it's a film or a
commercial or a tv show because now they
can't say no to you they can't [ __ ] with
you
because eventually you could become
somebody so kind of most likely you
ain't gonna be dick yeah but you did
this movie that and that's when some
people paid attention but for the most
part dog i've always had a shitty agent
always i've had like the coloring book
yeah and [ __ ] uh smith and weston you
know so what's your problem with the
comedy store now the comedy store for me
right now today i used to go let it work
out
there's nothing like working out
there's nothing like going on stage
we're gonna send 28 people
and going you know what i'm gonna talk
about cyberbullying simon duff leopard
high and dry
and going up there and going on a tirade
about it
and having a tape recorder in your
pocket okay
and you go home and listen to the tape
recorder you go i could use this i could
use that got laughs here what happens at
the comedy store now is it's so high
level
you ain't got time to dick and to go in
there and throw a lot of duds that's the
pro ball it's the pro ball you better
shine so
you know
i'm trying to [ __ ] so loud every
night every night every night so for me
to do what i want to do
right now what i need to be doing
i can't do it down there i feel you i
still come up with
you know what i'm saying and then bits i
got this classic joke i got bits at a
star and i don't want to be [ __ ]
listen bro
i gotta shoot something uh tomorrow in
the afternoon so that's why they dyed my
hair i'm doing a favor for a friend of
mine i'm playing a young basketball
coach then in september he's gonna shoot
me again with white hair but i got white
hair i can't go on stage talking about
eating [ __ ] and eating ass
so you got to talk about what's going on
in my life what really i'm saying like
i'm trying to really break it down i
could have done this special they even
asked justin to do a special dirty
if i would go all out and i'm like
you feel like you've outgrown that i
outgrew it yeah i'm on to storytelling
comparing what's going on then tonight
and how i'm different that's it every
comic goes through that though right
yeah you talk about what's relevant in
your life listen you want to do a
midnight show and people know we're
going to be dirty and we're going to
have a good time oh i'll go up there and
talk about [ __ ] sucking your liver
out yeah but
i'm not doing that [ __ ] at 8 o'clock
anymore no you know i don't want people
to go home and god he was dirty he was
funny but he was just dead he was vulgar
i see what you're saying that makes
sense
that's what always killed me
that's what always
made me defend
fighters in the ufc
and we've had this discussion already
and that's why i've taken comedy so
seriously maybe the last eight nine
years because of what i saw at the ufc
what do you mean guys that had a strong
weapon
but they refused to work on the rest of
their arsenal oh and then they get found
out because of the dependency of that
strong weapon and eventually and
eventually everyone sees it it's it's
horrible and i'm not talking about a guy
like houston alexander who couldn't
wrestle one day somebody put him on his
back and it was horrible he was back
there flying a turtle yeah you know but
with houston the first minute you were
in danger seeing [ __ ] animals flying
and [ __ ] like that well the game
revolves fast
ronda look at there's a bunch of guys
anthony pettis there's a lot of guys
where the game evolves super super fast
and it's so weird how
you know you see them on the card you
see the the ufc countdown yeah and then
be out there let me tell you something
when he feels my power oh yeah and i go
this guy's gonna lose yeah
and they show the other guy this time
this guy
did half his training at
jackson's and did the other half with
enzo gracie's yeah and this guy's still
at home on the farm with his friends and
his father-in-law yeah you're like what
the [ __ ] are you thinking yeah you're
better you know what i'm saying you got
to get better he said
my father was a assistant wrestling
coach at
the high school that's great guy i'm not
going to that's 1960 [ __ ] two he's
still thinking about what's that louie
what's that
what's that move when they get you know
half louis what's that i don't know
something else
i'm saying
this is the ufc [ __ ]
you miss it brendan no not the least bit
never
man how did you stumble upon the ufc
uh
like the first time i've ever seen it
no no right
you played cu bolt let's see you see you
boulder now why are you going to see you
bowled are you taking henzo gracie jiu
jitsu what are you doing i'm taking uh
some classes in the summer at easton's
bjj in boulder i'm going over there
after my training camp
because i was interested and i thought i
could do it maybe
and then i had a quick cup of coffee
with the buffalo bills training camp
and then realized you know that wasn't
gonna be a life for me you know it's
heartbreaking and then uh
a cardio kickboxing coach at la boxing i
was just training training training and
then it kind of just [ __ ] took off
and i met the right people meaning that
at the time
you know nate markhart's gym nate was in
the ufc
there was just guys coming in there guys
coming up me and shane car when shane
had one fight at the time he needed a
big guy to train with i was the new big
guy me and him linked up from there we
went to tease ko where was rashad evans
keith jardine just the who's who george
st pierre and she got into this cycle
and then
started taking fights and then [ __ ]
four fights in i get a call from the
ultimate fighter it's heavyweight season
boom off to the races got my take of the
chocolate factory how crazy is that
crazy
crazy
that's more crypt me pursuing fighting
is way more crazy than me pursuing
comedy my family went what the [ __ ] did
they oh my god my dad was like you're
this you're an idiot you're an idiot
literally do anything else my mom went
what are you doing okay i mean you guys
i mean he has you know me pretty well
i'm not aggressive dude i'm not an angry
guy
of a good work ethic
you know that's about it but i don't i
don't enjoy hurting people i don't want
to hurt people when was the first time
you got into a fight how old are you i
mean growing up with my older brother
left and right but on the street [ __ ]
man i mean bullies at school maybe
how old 12 13.
i mean like legit fight maybe uh
14 50 remember what you felt like did
you i was terrified
terrified
i was terrified fighting the ufc
terrified man
not you know some you know like the diaz
brothers or you know that you hear these
guys like cain velasquez or these guys
like it's in my blood i do this for free
what the [ __ ] that's what you animals i
would never do this for free i'm only
doing this because there's a camera
people pay tickets to watch this
it's crazy because i enjoyed it until i
was about 13
and i took a beating when i was 13.
that was ferocious broken nose
busted lips you know [ __ ] lumps to
the head
i busted his nose but in my world that
didn't do dick yeah the way that i mean
i was healed
i'm not angry anymore it was just a
physical you know
i started fighting when i was maybe five
when i moved from cuba to new york city
yeah i got into a couple scraps i got to
yeah i got hit in the head with a lunch
box uh yeah a [ __ ] uh
the the little containers in that yeah
and then there was this one kid i used
to scrap with a lot by that time i knew
karate his name was rudy the haitian he
was haitian him and his dad
and i fought that kid brendan shaw
ten times
finally his dad grabbed me
and held me arms and had rudy beat the
[ __ ] goddamn this was animalistic and he
took me upstairs and my mom pulled the
knife on him jesus christ and chased
them and the cops came and they said my
mom didn't have a knife so they didn't
press charges good for you man
we grew up doing it no no no then i went
to catholic school those years and i'm
assuming i had to scrap it too
when i was 13 now by this time i'm doing
karate yeah like i'm pretty going to the
gym and i'm sparring after class and i
would go to mario diaz's house at nine
and he would put we'd go to his basement
and beat
the [ __ ]
out of each other yeah the sheetrock was
busted everywhere no wrestling no mma
just karate flying sidekicks
around house kicks to the head we bought
the gear
we had the iron palm technique i mean we
were crazy
and then
right before
i quit karate
i got lit up in the gym one day
and i remember walking home you know
just boxing gloves and then karate just
[ __ ] around this kid was like a
purple belt
and i couldn't believe his quickness i
couldn't believe his footwork
i couldn't believe dick at that point i
had been doing karate you know [ __ ]
eight years i wasn't no bruce lee but i
knew what i was doing and i was like you
know what
fighting is definitely something i'm
just going to watch
like i was a roberto duran
fan and muhammad
[ __ ] i think for a lot of fighters i
think you know anthony rumble johnson
just retired they actually reached out
to me today
you know you're tired top of the game
ranked number two in the world and he'll
say i i'm worried about my brain man
like i see how a lot of this ends for
the guys and you know i'm worried about
brain drum stuff like that i'm i got a
lot of living to do man i'm only 30 or
29 where the [ __ ] is he's like you know
once you start thinking about the
repercussions of what you're doing
whether it's football
fighting it's probably time to get out
because the guy you're fighting is
really not thinking like that
you know
you know you look at the guys
you know like i'm not we probably didn't
know
and before muhammad ali they just kept
it headed but they just didn't know they
just assumed you know who knows you
watched concussion yeah very interesting
i watched it twice on planes me too i
assault on playing tremendous you could
only watch them
at the house
that movie shocked me
did it shocked me not me
it shocked me because
i thought the nfl was better to their
players
i thought that well i remember i did i
did
i did that
with
barcelona
and i spent the whole weekend one time
with bosworth
me and him just chatting i loved him
first of all i loved it
but he filled me in on one weekend of
how they find him they wouldn't they
wouldn't even give him a game check
because he would wear his shirt outside
of his hair yeah so he well no he wore
like the mystery [ __ ] something crazy
so they would find him the amount of his
check yeah they took his house he had to
go to hawaii he's a businessman but it's
a business jack sharks and then we've
discussed it before with lee how i never
knew until maybe two years ago the
longevity of a running back in the nfl
is three years three years
you know because i grew up i know now
campbell look at him because those are
the three world championships those are
the freaks yeah he doesn't remember the
the guys but that that's all you
remember like but and also it might be a
little better now but at the this
probably three years ago you know what
the average career a ufc fighter is do
you guys know yeah a year and a half
year and a half the average career in
the ufc
that was i think it was a stat three
years ago but and maybe it's a little
long maybe it's not because they're
making cuts but you got to remember in
the ufc for all those main card guys you
know there's a shitload of undercard
dudes
year and a half is average career i
always leveled it this way but if i got
the call from uh whoever jimmy smits
dana white whoever the odds maker is
today honestly this is in my head
i don't think a 22 year old
or 24 year old would know this
i think i'd have a year and a half to
accomplish my mission
that's what i really personally think
that you have to go into the ufc knowing
that you're going to fight
seven times in one of this world
championship and that's decide what your
next move is
that's fair so you go in there you fight
on two or three prelim cards you knock
the [ __ ] out they put you on the
main card low end yep
and you keep that's not simulation
six fights you're in a championship
fight yeah you're six and or you could
talk a little [ __ ] see where you go from
there yeah see where you go from there
the first year in the ufc you do fight
three or four times the first year that
that's how i was accepted i fought four
yeah i had three knockouts all in under
a minute you know and then they toss you
a vet it's fine you pass that test
another vet crow cop fine you pass that
test now i'm what five and on the ufc
four known the ufc then you start
[ __ ] with the big dogs you're talking
about the top ten guys top five guys you
know and then you find out you know are
you gonna
are you gonna be one of these legends
are you gonna be the guy like is this
your path you know or you want to be
a journeyman where it's probably not for
you you know you're not going to be
making those buku dollars you're not
going to be the guy who you know is is
selling jerseys and stuff like that well
you know i mean you go into it because
first of all
and i don't know if you're listening to
these people or not but always remember
you do this [ __ ] because you absolutely
love it
or you know or you have no options joey
or a lack of options that's what
fighting comes from i'm gonna tell you
something i had lack of options in
1991.
i was a roof and making maybe 40 a year
i was probably picking up another 20 on
the side doing odd jobs roofing and
selling cars 60 after sixty sixty and
boulder in eighty seven you're gonna eat
dick okay terrible my wife probably made
at the time forty cutting hair downtown
that was it hardcape to you
once we broke up
i could learn how to do anything in a
week
you know i could take dana white's job
and yeah i'm one of those [ __ ]
yeah
but i knew that the ceiling for money
was gonna be low and bold
and that's why i said if i'm gonna be
broke i might as well be broke
doing what i want to do yeah when i
first got on stage again when those
people mentioned these things to me that
i should do comedy i didn't like it
then one day it snowed and i watched the
movie punchline with tom hanks yeah and
i watched that movie and i'm like wait a
second
i might like this you know what i'm
saying i like that i need a family i
need to hang out with people
i need to do stand up
once i did it in denver and i had a
conversation with matt woods i did it up
in greeley at the denver training camp
the for the first night they go to the
rookies my friend had the contract okay
so we i did comedy in front of the
denver broncos in the train i was i
bombed it was just a bomb in the second
time back but it was the second time i
got on stage yeah
and the third time i got a stage again
was that the comedy works and i did
something else for bill
bill
i forget what his [ __ ] that don't
matter he had a motorcycle shop in fort
collins i did something else for him and
i gotta tell you something after four
times
it i loved it more than cocaine
boom it was the first thing that i i
knew i wanted to do
i knew i wanted to try it
and you also think you [ __ ] up the
money
at that time
i was disenchanted with money yeah
because money had gotten me all my
problems yeah and even when i had money
and aspiring and i had the fifty
thousand we can had horrible problems i
wasn't happy yeah it didn't make me any
happier
what was the happy part of it that i
bought a new car yeah well then i went
to the lobster tails and showed off to
people no matter by the time i was 28
i was this disappearing
yeah i was like this is [ __ ] good
for you all my life i wanted money to do
what to have to test the rosa
to show you i had a picture of a tesla
rosa on my wall i'm going to get a
touchdown a white one in north boulder
i'm paying 450 rent i'm going to test
the roads that's how [ __ ] i am yeah
and i'm looking at this thing going
really is that what i really wanted
that's not who i ever was
growing up bro my mom had money yeah i
didn't like it
i didn't like it i would take my chains
off in front of kids
my mom would go why are you
these kids lived 10 in the [ __ ]
bedroom i had a cable tv in my own air
conditioner in my home with a carpeting
yep and i slept by myself not with three
or your brothers in the room with a fan
in the summer i was embarrassed they
would go let's go to your house you
don't want to go to my house yeah i live
in a bad place
i lived on 205 west stadius you had my
big room yeah [ __ ] color tv in my
bedroom with stereo you know
so i never liked that whole thing yeah
and it all dawned on me if i'm gonna be
you know what i'd rather travel every
night you know at that time i listened
to bob sega music and bon jovi wanted
deader alive yeah and i read the lenny
uh
bruce bruce book which marco from the
chopped restaurant gave me lenny bruce
live
from the
carnegie hall i got to bring it in this
week and listen to it once i read that
book
i was not game over
about him living at the chelsea hotel
and he would only do comedy after strip
clubs at strip clubs
so you'd [ __ ] a stripper every night
he'd get a 10 bag on heroin he'd go back
to the chelsea hotel sleep till two
get his pipe sucked and then crank jokes
at night yeah perfect killing it perfect
who doesn't want that [ __ ] light
brother shot let me read some shout outs
and we'll get you out of here perfect
man we'll close it up with some comedy
[ __ ] here
cleo you know i love you thank you for
always listening to supporting us and
give us your love
mackenzie tittle
tony gallegos
lauren rosenka always thinking about you
my little [ __ ] genius cassius morris
the my favorite puerto rican renee
and carcione
juan montoya and sean p smith i'm
watching you
the la lingas family you know i got your
back [ __ ] always hope dad is
doing well
and my man larry get a job [ __ ]
you look good man i'm happy that you're
doing the stand up that you're not
faking the funk i'm happy that you're
turning tv shows down that you don't
want to be brian boswell dude
what was the name of the movie he did i
forget man it's terrible bone cold
something like that not amazing
i know that's how it goes behind
millions yeah what are you doing what do
you do yeah disease in your head
i'm doing a podcast right now what i'm
smacking the [ __ ] head go get that
motorcycle and go in and be stoned
oh julie it was brutal
you have to watch it i appreciate you
man and just being uh just supporting
and [ __ ] oh no dog i know when
somebody's faking the [ __ ] yeah i've
lived in this town for 20 years yeah and
i know the people are trying to get rich
quick those are the people that i give
them rope i just need them yeah
bro keep doing it why would you call cbs
tomorrow
you should tell them
oh yeah get a special now oh shut
but with you i like how you even mingle
at the store yeah you're just a regular
guy that wants to go on stage that night
i was watching it i wanted to see if you
got nervous yeah when i see you walking
you know you didn't have nobody where
yeah you know no coach with you
you didn't have
there's no drama [ __ ] no you were there
by yourself and yeah i was really
impressed
how you were walking around the back
room this was the main room again with
joe and al madrigal yeah burke chrysler
i mean it was a [ __ ] murderer's role
and you were walking around like [ __ ]
you didn't give a [ __ ]
we had a little conversation our agent
was there some other guy
and then you got on stage i waited i'll
listen to you
and by the time i got to the door
you were talking about uh you know
college and
now the guy was kicking the power
whatever the [ __ ] and i just walked out
of it because i had no place to stand i
was [ __ ] back
but again your composure on stage
you're out doing sets you're not waiting
for somebody to come to your house and
they'll rub your balls so i respect all
that type of [ __ ] bro i appreciate you
brother i do
i really [ __ ] do what'd you think of
the fights this weekend
they were good best fighter on the
planet joanna chang chain
boy
i just have nothing else to say there
you go dog she impresses me more me too
man than anything i've ever seen in my
life it's like if you don't want to
learn how to be a fighter
just watch her i agree that's it and you
know what i like about it the most
she paints her toenails and her
fingernails right all the time keeps it
that's a sexy [ __ ] right there i
agree brother when she's smacking people
my dick guitar
wants a chick that wants to talk about
stupid [ __ ] i hear you man kick boxing
and she went she's supporting the seals
i don't give a [ __ ] i got a polish chick
that [ __ ] smacking [ __ ]
every six months she shows up and just
[ __ ] smacks [ __ ] i read a stat
the last three fights she's had seven
hundred and something strikes compared
to two hundred and something from her
opponents yeah i mean she's she's been
crazy you know those three fights about
75 minutes and just doing work and she's
uh like a point fighter yeah and a
fighter mixed into one which is rare she
always scores one with that last kick
the dang monster see you later
monster you know what people i don't
know if you know this those good things
add up jack hell yeah 10 good things to
your [ __ ] leg the next day you're at
that chinese dude and [ __ ] lanka shim
and husband
get in the [ __ ] bro that if you ever
if you're ever in the valley guys
go to lancashire hesby from 12 to 3 they
got a happy hour shoulders feet
and calves
you give [ __ ] the guy a fin you give
him a 10 if you're having a good day
if not give him the small fin
and give him the 20 spot
30 minutes is the best sometimes after
jiu jitsu i can't take it i'm a fat [ __ ]
i love i go in there i give him the
small 20. yeah he rubs my feet he takes
all the blood out of my chest
i'm about to go there [ __ ] right now
oh he puts your feet in there i'm about
to piss my pants so i gotta [ __ ] get
out of here wait where are you going
he's so bad you just got it
10 minutes ago what's the matter with
you
you just got here we're talking about
joanna
she's the best man
what's your next move you're going on
tour what's up where's the tour open up
uh starts in australia in uh brisbane
then i'm in uh melbourne auckland
and uh sydney sydney sold out so they're
trying to add another show there
and then uh june 22nd i'm in new york
gotham comedy club
and then july 28th i'm at the life actor
in long beach the night before the big
ufc anaheim breaking that [ __ ] down so
things are good man good for you yeah
t5k.com for all that
i'm proud of you're a [ __ ] animal now
get out of here i'll close up this [ __ ]
you're the best brother i love you get
back to you guys it's a pleasure to see
you let's get that story down so we get
you and this is not happening like a
[ __ ] thank you
thanks man
and that's it and that's natalie i don't
know if you people know this i don't
know if he forgot to tell you
[ __ ]
tuesday night me and lee had a [ __ ]
accent monday night monday night i'm
sorry and you're thinking like joey what
type of accent
listen man we ate
two of those chocolate bars two
cantaloupe things
and maybe four or five stars a piece
guys i've been doing this for [ __ ]
years but you guys you guys witnessed it
every night
i was seeing double
lee how many times i just nod out and
falsely yeah from more times than usual
pretty and like
yeah you you were like hey i just don't
just sit down on the couch for a little
bit i must have drank eight gallons of
water
i was saying i'm taking like this and
guy fungal medication i'm finally
breaking down because i've been put i
don't talk about the fungi toenail no
more you know why because i've been
putting the
baking soda on it
since january first i wanted a baking
soda treatment and guess what
the toe is still lurking in there the
fungi like i got rid of three quarters
of it but there's still a little fungi
lurking
the doctor told me listen you can put
anything you want on the gasoline
it lives in your body do this thing they
did a blood test i did the [ __ ] five
so i'm on the third day of pills let me
tell you something those pills knock you
the [ __ ] out
they zack your body you don't know where
the [ __ ] you are so i think
because i did those and what we did
monday night but guys
lee and i and you how many times have
you heard us on here talk about food we
ordered two [ __ ] pizzas at a quarter
to one in the morning
first off i could not drive i tell you
guys honestly from the bottom of my
heart
i i i gotta get more props whether it's
the cantaloupe candy the taffy
the stars of death
and uh moon chocolate you guys were on
friday on that
but you guys will never know how [ __ ]
up we were the other night
yeah it was uh and i was i was mildly
[ __ ] up but then like i i passed out
like after i was worried about you
because i and then but then after you
left i passed out i woke up at four in
the morning here
four in the morning you passed out
though yeah i was just just riding my
seat i always i was worried if like
someone would just walked up and saw
like all these lights just look at me
passed out
guys i'm sorry yeah i was [ __ ] gone
but thank you for supporting that was
nice
i liked that big brown came up tonight
we spoke the other night at the comedy
club i wish him well guys
there's a lot of dudes out there in la
that fake the funk and i gotta tell you
something
this kid's not faking the funk he works
hard he does get sandwiched in between
heat
uh
you know i don't know how the [ __ ] he
does it i would rather my first couple
times if i got sandwiched in between
dane cook and joe rogan
i'd run the [ __ ] out of there so
if uh he's coming to one of your town
support go watch him man the kid's
really trying and you can't take that
away from anybody that's the type of
[ __ ] that you know impresses the [ __ ]
out of me that he's not doing he's not
talking to talk he's walking the walk
so i tip my heart out to you as far as
tipping my heart out to you what do you
do when you want a snack what all you
can find is junk food you rely on your
self-control to resist the temptation
that's never gonna work
so what do you do you eat the junk food
you eat the garbage
no more start snacking healthy
with nature bucks nature box makes
quality snacks that actually taste great
delicious and they're better for you and
created with high quality ingredients
and are free from artificial colors
flavors or sweetness so you can feel
great about snacking
my personal favorite are the plantains
the chocolate non-noms
the biscott the lemon biscott i mean
nature box recently made their service
even better now you can order as much as
you want as often as you want with no
minimum purchase required and you can
cancel at any time it's simple here you
go you ready write this down go to
naturebox.com
and check out their snack
there are over 100 snacks to choose from
and they're constantly adding delicious
new snacks
you choose the snacks you want and they
deliver them you're ready for this right
to your door there you are sitting there
you did a bong you're wondering what's
going on awesome bing bong and there's
nature box all right with nature bucks
you never get bored you know why because
they got new snacks each month inspired
by real customer feedback and if you
ever want to try a snack if you ever try
a snack you don't like
nature box will replace it for free
this is what i'm gonna do for you right
you know i love you guys i always want
you to be healthy and right now you'll
save even more guidance nature box is
offering our family 50 off your first
order when you go to naturebox.com
joey it's that easy listen 50 off of
those snacks healthy delicious they're
good for you i mean
i don't even know what to tell you the
cherry berry bonanza the mini belgian
waffles the whole wheat vanilla animal
cookies are you kidding me or what
the vanilla bean wafers listen
naturebox.com joey 50 off your first
order because you know i take care of my
family again
naturebox.com
joey number two helix sleep you're
unique
you don't walk like everybody you don't
talk like everybody you don't sleep like
everybody so why is your mattress one
size fits all okay you know let's say
you weigh 200 pounds and your wife she
can't stop eating twinkies she's up
there 660. she's ready to see dr
kazarian because a custom mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until today until tonight uncle joey's
here to take care of you introducing
helix sleep when you can buy a mattress
online it's that simple customized for
you for hundreds of dollars instead of
thousands i'm gonna save you thousands
go to helixsleep.com answer a few simple
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile
used to build you the most comfortable
mattress
you will ever sleep on your mattress
will arrive right at your door in about
a week and shipping is 100 free
on the um and for couples helix
customizes each side of the mattress who
does this
helix customers report 30 percent 30
percent improvement in overall sleep you
sleep like a baby you got 100 nights to
try it out and if you don't love it
don't pick it up for free and give you
100 refund
no questions asked who's better than
that that's why everybody from gq to
forbes are talking about helix sleep go
to helixsleep.com right now slash joey
and get fifty dollars off your first
thought again helix sleep.com slash joey
and get
off your first daughter i want to thank
naturebox i want to thank helix sleep
and i also want to thank annette
for the supplements the bats the steel
bats the kettlebells
the apparel me i live off the
supplements
whether it's the new post energy drink
with the coconut flavor
to the the shroom tech
to the alpha brain this is what i'm
doing hem force protein i'm all on it
i'm 54. i need all the help i can get
honor that i trust go to honor.com right
now and press enter church boom get 10
off your order delivered to your door
that's it and that's that i love you
[ __ ] i want to thank brendan
schaub i want to thank my little brother
lisa and i want to thank you guys for
being family may 25th 8 30 stage number
two the ice house the workout i'm
starting from scratch new material new
ideas 10 bucks you're in and out of
there by 9 30 quarter 10 you can still
give the wife a stabbing have a great
weekend i love you stay black uncle joey
always loves you
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you